that's what's so tough about being a hockey
parent right the puck HED his up quick shot
Tyson Forster and the save by Kaden Primo another
story in this game of course the son of long time
flyer Keith Primo who we're told is also here at
the game effort to find him in the crowd here K
one of three go tenders for this Canadians team
they've gone with the three goal tender setup
here's forer Quick Pass to won lton the backand
and ring and off fire and now it's San good look
there nice pass there by Tyson Forester getting
it to Scotty lton settled it down ah just off
that inside of the post a half an inch more to
the left that goes in the back of the net but
Scotty lton winning that opening draw there are
the Canadians trying to get to work offensively
for the first time Baron at the point sends it in
along fin will play it back around behind the it
back out to the point and now it's Baron again
a shot and they score there is a screen set up
in front Don Monahan was there I don't know if he
deflected it but it eludes Aron and I'm not sure
how that got in but it's one nothing Montreal get
a piece of it and there's Justin Baron Montreal
Canadians Defender and there's the tip right there
going right in Sam Aron's glove a great tip down
uh in between the glove and the pad and you can't
fault a golender on that one yet you almost have
to tie up a stick if you're the defender of the
flyer there think that was tip it maybe Cony
follows up chips to cier cier waiting bounces one
actually floats one that makes it all the way to
the glove of Primo zamula has it there but only
got it as far as sarosi back in big forward that
puck off to Michael petta comes back out to Savar
he'll Blast One deflected score flutters right on
in as Sosi went to to the slot and the Canadians
have two shots and two goals and a two nothing
lead charge there to the bench but I believe it
went off Mr sloski and and just up and over Sam
Arison maybe not but just unfortunate that's a
hard shot to do there for svar is coming on your
off Wing trying to get that towards the net it
goes off Frost Stick up and over Sam Aron and in
the net but just too unfortunate breaks there for
the Flyers leading to Two Shots on goal knocks it
down with his glove plays it to the left side
for kekney kkny will go across ice with it but
Canadians will find that Baron got it ahead kept
in by Walker got it with his stick into the slot
connect the off the cont back in front now it's
tippet he scores eventually someone shot the puck
and it's tippet who buries it and the Flyers are
on the board it's two to one that Puck and fired
it from a terrible angle there's John Walker
a good keep there TK eyes in the back of his
head over to Cs and then tip it somehow go go
gadget arm gets the puck on a stick and fires
that thing here's the big reach there by ow and
tip it and slides it in there not a great angle
had to elevate over Baron there who's laying out
to try and block that shot so a huge goal for the
Flyers far in across the Montreal line SES to
the middle drops it back zamula zamula down low
piling angle shot save rebound batted at by Brick
it didn't go offensive zone here of the Canadians
by the Flyers and just haven't uh really kind of
uh relay into some nice shots and a good chance
here's Coffield getting behind the defense save
Arison here's a look at these couple of these
chances here both sides here Cole Coffield Gets
behind the defense him and Sam Arison that's his
second save TI It Ste rolls up with it then gets
knocked down and apparently he went down on his
own now he's got the [__] back with a shot off
iron again three post the Flyers of it already
to go through the five hole and there's Owen tip
it that's shoot J's mentality beats him there but
can't beat that post ow and TI and now Seer lobs
one back toward the slot loose pit save primo and
he's able to hang on and this is the last one
gared halfway just creating Havoc all over the
ice sneaks up and steals the puck from him got
it to Couer who finds farab who drops it back the
rist to one it but a shot off the post again four
posts for the Flyers already in this game the Puck
there in the opening puck drop pretty impressive
that little kid love that name speed was going
plenty of that in this game here is sealer with a
shot the flex save rebound fary goes across creas
they dig it never goes in was going to put that
one home great play by sealer here great shot
gets deflected there's the pass over to C's back
door and oh he's the backhand of Monahan there
backhanding that one out of there wow it is behind
him there sneaking through the Fly ball wow man
holding gets it back to frost and now it's dri
de moves to the middle deals it off for frost
Frost holds fires and Scar Jamie rale quickly has
his first point is a flyer Morgan Frost the power
play tally and the flyer is a power play goal in
getting this three straight games it's tied at two
first gets it to frost and there's the movement
by Jamie Dale gets it to frost a little fake shot
kind of freezes everybody especially the penalty
killer right in front of him there there's the
little shake and bake and there's the low gluff
shot there Suzuki still has it seconde captain
of this Canadians team their leading scorer lays
it off for Anderson Anderson barreling his way
in couldn't finish it off here's Josh Anderson
he's a bull he's a great skater this played in
by Anderson all the way to the other side Walker
Le man to halfway who finds won Waton to the
circle to tip it for the shot off fire and what
else is new they got everything turn and here's
tip it right there great pass by lton loing back
to Baron back in only as far as connect me gives
the forer right up the gut P forer cutting on in
swings wide the shot save rebound another save and
there's Forster with the wheels beats the defense
been wide and almost gets that one short side with
the Flyers there's conect the probably that one
is blocked off oh he's a turnover cier the shot
but Kaden Primo ready game here 604 to go in the
third now entering the toy to r four minutes to
play and look out here Anderson charging a big
save by AR all the way back across rise Dale's
not on the ice he's got the buck risale with
the pass he's got frost in a goal stve Primo
holy smokes look at the eyes on this guy look
at the the heat on that pass springing Morgan
Frost and trying to catch reall who may have
saved the game right there firers have it back
one more push there's concy with Lon connly
moving up to L the shut oh the save by Primo
spectacular and now the other way it's Anderson
Josh Anderson rumbling on in save Arison loose
fck onahe comes back out in front Anderson again
here's Josh and coming in so mono e mono with Sam
Arison steady with his choices in the shootout
swing in from the left wing this time Exar Sean
C is he's coming in there and he does go right
on the ice Suzuki over 50% for his career 11 for
21 four for seven this year deliberately on in
and Harrison just waited him out it just kind
of Waits him out there doesn't get fooled by The
Fakes and he's seven for 15 in his career three
for seven this year way to the left wing and on
in save Harrison just held his ground the blue
paint there Coffield coming in taking away that
angle there it's seal the deal here Bobby Brink
Bobby rink ends it with a goal swings way to the
right wing and he goes go to the back hand and
the save by Primo he had him down couldn't get it
over him he did Elevate this Puck but just a good
job by Primo getting that blocker over there as
well oh man just a little bit ESS was three for
five in his career and shootout ATT TS two for
four this year has to score Cuts in deakes and
he's stopped by Arison three for three Aron denies
all the attempts the Flyers win the hockey game